depuis un an et l'apparition du coc vie
de beaucoup de secteurs sont touchés
souffrent de la crise
mais il ya bien un secteur pour qui ça
va un peu mieux que les autres c'est
celui de la chirurgie esthétique
benjamin castaldi peux vous en dire
quelque chose
ils ont fait d'ailleurs un sujet sur tf1
benjamin vous qui avez refait refaire
voler jeunes et braves arrêter avec ça
jama mari mais je vous jure sur la tête
de mes enfin possible mais je vous en
fait comme comme lg oui aux as il fait
une allergie à quelque chose et
énergique quelque chose mais je vous
jure je derrière on fait du tout je vous
le dirai ma main et je vous ferai moi
ils vont me le cash on ne joue que
j'avais caché pour les sens j'ai dû leur
plaire mais c'est vrai nom mais benjamin
c'est pamela anderson
mais comme j'ai comme j'ai comme j'ai
maigri peut-être que les 10 à bord
je vous le dis sinon laissant ressortir
aussi s'épanouir ou non ce moment on est
honnête benjamin donc faut le dire il
avait une séance gratuite à une
certaines cliniques de paris a et il en
a profité et on a regardé bien avec
kelly ses lèvres et à la marque de deux
piqûres
voilà et ouais alors où vous avez des
gammes chez vous ou bien vous avez fait
d'assurer les combats laisser le temps
du sujet pour préparer à votre défense
et pas depuis juin les cabinets
d'esthétique enregistre une hausse des
demandes d'environ 20%
les patients ont eu un retour sur soi
une envie de prendre soin d'eux depuis
ils ont eu le temps de se regarder dans
le miroir
dans les cabinets le profit des patients
à changer davantage d'hommes et des
jeunes pour qu'ils les écrans ont été un
miroir déformant ont été beaucoup sur
les écrans et se sont regardés en
particulier dans les applications qui
transforme le visage ce qu'on appelle le
snap tchad syndrome avec la demande de
ressembler à leur image la crise du coc
vide a changé notre rapport au miroir
mais elle n'a pas détruit les diktats de
la beauté
alors c'est vrai que la chirurgie
esthétique est un grand boum de la
chirurgie esthétique et je voudrais dire
juste un truc pendant le sujet le sol
qui a reconnu avec linux et mac je vous
jure que c'est vrai il s'est traduite au
seul sujet vrai ou pas vous l'aviez
abbas et la clinique
non je vais je mets dans une clinique
mais faire des soins de chirurgie jamais
refaire les lèvres
je viens dès demain avec une attestation
de la clinique pour donner un petit
billet d'avion vous connais on connaît
vos magouilles
non j'ai enquêté un peu ce qu'est ce qui
cartonne c'est pas la chirurgie
esthétique c'est la médecine esthétique
c'est les interventions un peu légère et
j'ai appelé une clinique donc la fameuse
clinique ils m'ont donné le top 3 des
interventions donc c'est les injections
de botox contour des yeux les assaillent
la semaine avait fait ça ça oui je les
fais des injections de botox l'acide
hyaluronique
mais ici là mais vous le contour des
yeux en fait il est très grand c'est
vrai d'autres contour des yeux prend
tout autant il ya très longtemps
il ya neuf mois il ya les épilation
laser et le relâchement du visage pour
faire aux visages un peu qui tombe il a
fait ce qu'il a fait aussi quand vous
avez fait le relâchement du visage non
le l'épilation laser ne t'a pas fait en
fait non mais le relâchement du visage
les relations non c'est pas fait encore
qu'a faite le
le délai semble la 4g beaucoup de
chirurgie esthétique a énormément à
celle d'une pollution liposuccion les
yeux les cheveux bah c'est pas parce que
l'effet des poches et cernes
là je veux saluer l'évolution bon ça lui
va bien c'est joli ouais ouais parce que
c'est ce que delphine dentyne je crois
je cherche une clinique pour son homme
non mais c'est important de prévenir
certains pourraient donc l'entreprise de
btp plus tôt il est très bon alors il
est très beau rouge il est très bon et
c'est pour ça qu'il faut préserver cette
beauté le plus le faire tôt ce que je
veux dire c'est qu'une soeur géré tôt et
on boit sur benjamin il fait des trucs
super naturel et c'est comme ça
les hommes en moyenne nationale ils
deviennent de plus en plus beaux et en
faisant des petites choses ça permet de
tenir la beauté non mais alors non mais
ho est arrêté on a deux exemples ici qui
vous met dans la merde c'est super mais
je suis désolé qu'ils allaient chercher
la turbie esthétique ici vous dites la
vérité oui vous il a été bon jean michel
et benjamins ils ont fait tout faire du
vélo en salle au plafond va faire
pernikoff alors jamais non pas trois
bières et regarder bernard qui était un
peu le plus âgé de tous regardé les
formidables dallas il a fait des trucs
tâter le truc mais là en fait jamais
fléchir et non j'avais peur mais sans
non plus ici je vais vous dire un truc
c'est que en plus moi moi je suis pas
contre le seul problème c'est j'ai peur
de s'habituer et de devoir y retourner
souvent pascal assy l'acide hyaluronique
dont tu parles
il paraît que ça disparaît très vite
lassé saint gilles verdez à gérer le
problème un peu psychomoteur au niveau
de la tête
j'ai besoin d'injections de botox
médical mais comme castaldi pictou pour
la chirurgie esthétique plus aujourd'hui
même si c'est pas lâcher au geste est là
sous les lunettes et tous vous très très
nerveuse entre bg non mais vous vous
devez faire quelque chose si vous
referiez quoi vous à vous avez de la
chance vous avez une très belle peau
parce que même là vous souriez tout le
temps vous n'avez pas de femme doit vous
n'êtes pas très
je vous le jour qui n'est jamais rien
mais c'est sans être désobligeant cyrine
quand je vois en photo les moyens ya
huit ans a pris les habitants n'étaient
pas bons et la mêlée mais tout le monde
dit vous êtes devenu beau alors soit
c'est soit c'est la réussite et l'argent
qui vous auront du beau jeu c'est le
bistouri mais il le jour en face de
gauche
abo
[Rires]
cette année renault va arrêter les
hommes se bonifie en vieillissant c'est
très injuste fait d'accord avec moi à 30
ans un homme n'est pas fini il est dans
la norme
voilà merci merci merci des deux